على مرمى البصر يمتد الدمار الذي خلفه
الزلزال في شمال غربي سوريا حل دمار
الزلزال فوق دمار الحرب ليخلف وضعا يتفق
الجميع على انه كارثي لكن هذا الاجماع لا
يتحقق عندما يتعلق الامر بسبل مواجهته
انتظرت الامم المتحده سته ايام لارسال اول
قافله مساعدات وانتظرت بضعه ايام اخرى
ليصل وفد يمثلها الى المناطق المنكوبه
للاطلاع على الحاجات الانسانيه بعد
الزلزال اطلق الامين العام للامم المتحده
نداء لتمويل الاحتياجات الانسانيه
للمتضررين في سوريا الذين قدر عددهم بتسعه
ملايين
اعلن اطلاق الامم المتحده نداء لجمع ما
قيمته
397 مليون دولار من اجل تقديم مساعدات
انسانيه للمتضررين من الزلزال في سوريا
وسيغطي هذا فتره تمتد ثلاثه اشهر
لا يعرف هل سيثير تقسيم هذه المساعدات
جدلا كالذي تثيره المعابر الان فقبل هذا
الاعلان اعلن غوتيريج عن موافقه الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد على مرور المساعدات عبر
المعابر مع تركيا واكد ذلك وكيله للشؤون
الانسانيه
نرسل المساعدات الى شمال غربي سوريا منذ
سنوات عده
واس
دي بحجم المساعدات بسبب الحاجه المتزايده
جراء الزلزال
اعطاء الاسد سلطه على مرور المساعدات عبر
المعابر مع تركيا واعلان سماحه باستخدام
معبرين اضافيين اغضبت الدفاع المدني
السوري في شمال سوريا قال مديره رائد صالح
ان ذلك منح النظام مكاسب سياسيه مجانيه
اما وحده تنسيق الدعم التابعه للائتلاف
الوطني السوري المعارض فقد دعت الامم
المتحده والمجتمع الدولي لتحمل مسؤولياتهم
واعتبار شمال غرب سوريا منطقه منكوبه اذا
يستمر الجدل بشان المعابر رغم حجم الكارثه
التي خلفها الزلزال فخلال الفتره الاخيره
سمح بدخول المساعدات من معبر باب الهوى
دون غيره لان الامم المتحده لم تمنح
تفويضا بذلك بسبب رفض روسيا بالخصوص التي
تعتبر استخدام هذه المعابر انتهاكا
للسياده السوريه
ورغم ان النظام اعلن من قبل انه سيسمح
بمرور المساعدات من مناطق سيطرته الى
مناطق المعارضه فان ذلك لم يحدث حتى الان
هذه قافله امميه اخرى تدخل من معبر باب
الهوى وتتالف من اثنتين وثلاثين شاحنه
تحمل مواد اغاثيه مختلفه وهذه اول قافله
تدخل من معبر باب السلامه الى شمال سوريا
بعد موافقه النظام لا يبدو ان ايقاع دخول
هذه المساعدات يتناسب مع حجم الاحتياجات
في شمال غربي سوريا فهناك يعيش نحو اربعه
ملايين ونصف مليون سوري اصبحوا كلهم
تقريبا في حاجه الى مساعدات لكن بالنسبه
لهم المساعدات الانسانيه لا تصل حسب
حاجتهم وانما وفق حسابات سياسيه لم تهتم
يوما بحجم الكوارث